since the Second World War there have
only been two years in which a British
soldier was not killed on active duty
but for some the end of the war is just
the beginning of the battle more than 40
people who served in the UK Armed Forces
have taken their own lives so far this
year alone and this week I sat down with
some of the toughest men I've ever
interviewed talking about one of the
hardest things to speak about mental
health here at the Brighton improve and
boxing club veterans are marking the
centenary of the First World War in a
unique way I am one with these more than
20
[Music]
Lee McFarlin parachute regiment
[Applause]
[Music]
Jim Walker former 22 SES peaceful team
they joined the Armed Forces as
teenagers now these three friends are
trying to raise awareness and money for
former colleagues who are struggling and
who they believe their country has
forgotten the remembrance rumble charity
boxing match pitchers former members of
the SAS against X US Special Forces in a
year where 42 former members of the
Armed Forces took their own lives the
money is important but just as crucial
is seeing veterans as tough as these
took openly about mental health did any
of you guys struggle with your own
mental again I've struggled you know and
again it's not so much I just have it
obviously well I'm leaving the military
I went and done security so I went from
one battle glance for another one and
that was fine because it was just one
transition to to back into private
security my winnings children I left
them because actually I was ready for
myself general and I go back to how many
it was PTSD but you know the stresses
terms of life do you're not used to
military actually come on top and you
know there has been times my wife in the
military because I was used to
and it get done and then as the
civilians you asked for it you see a lot
getting out the distress is it's not
just about being having a mental health
issue every bt st PTSD or like you
actually find a certain veterans are
coming out these guys mangoes may have
never played before the council then
also they're getting out and they're
being told to fend for themselves so
they never had those life skills i do in
the military at 16 so i don't know any
freaked out now - yep but real
settlement is something that's a
starting that they join you should start
learning about you know things that
happen in civvy Street and like I say
predominantly the guide that set you off
in the city street now I may be some
garden all the way through the ranks
spent twenty four thirty years in the
military and it is the rent of captain a
world unto him and he's out there pass
directly to get himself Xuan didn't see
any through a nice big pension he's
never been a sue be somewhat right has
he got to put me in the city street he
doesn't know so that's when you need to
visit someone is probably bit on me out
with Tennessee Singh who comes back in
and says right okay without any
direction of this guy but this is this
is where it is just as much that this is
what you need to know Jobson qualify
reduces lollipop math it's insane we
leave and you know we have millions
spent on this for training going back to
the military to start off when you turn
up and definitely they want we get
taught how to wash out the shower and
how to shave and how to make a bet when
you're legal
don't teach me it's there's paperwork if
you want to do a course there's a thank
you very much
since the beginning and I think
Christmas across the board for suicides
anyway I think that's when it rises so
you know when the figure does look like
it's going to slow down anytime soon
that way you know the I wouldn't say
that for this correct there isn't
actually data
veterans are taking their life I wonder
if that is something that you think
would be a good idea actually
shape sort of information yes there is
there has been campaigns to actually get
a central database and I should work
with so many charities like combat
stress the RBL and most well-known
Sculptra heroes and actually states of
okay wherever your funds going live you
found something that you've helped I was
then gone to commit suicide because one
of the things that Chinese do is they
help you for a certain period of time
and then they just push like a door and
that's like they're taking the box and
the government you know from the
military point of view as well I just
saw a schema to start with in the wrong
range recently which is a mentoring
system whereby ties compare I can
actually feel part of the system again
and I think you know as a prisoner
coming out of prison without the
prologue period or you know some sort of
tie back to helping transition back into
series 3 I think some guys not all guys
but some guys need that from the
military as well they do you think to
you enough period or something like that
where they can dip back in if they need
to and feel part of something do you
think there's more support for people
leaving prison than you have in the
obviously possibly possibly there is you
know there's a lot of structure around
leaving prison and there's a lot of
feeling there's a lot of so much
preparation work with courses and all
that sort now I'm not saying that the
army don't do anything at all but they
could do more we're commemorating a
hundred years since the end of the First
World War
how are you can be remembering that day
it's a long day I mean it's it's a day
when we do traditionally you know we've
all been in combat situations ourselves
you know we were remember our own we
remember
and more importantly you know it's about
the whole thing that the whole deal we
know from from way back it's not just
like this today it does just one
conflict you knows country's been a
conflict repeatedly over the last you
know since since those war since World
War one you know with repeatedly you
know you've got things up Borneo Malaya
you know all these different campaigns
all the way through so this country's
now been without conflict and so it's
about just remembering the people that
have been been bold enough to go out on
behalf of a democratically elected
government and do something for us you
know and just you know remember and is
there any people in particularly yeah
there's also you know we've all lost
friends and colleagues so yeah I always
have a drink even even the days when
they lost their lives
I'll always stop remember and have a
drink and yeah never forgot ya know
obviously actually regiment so we've got
a loss a lot of guys over the last 18
years since back so again it's it's a
time for me to remember my friends that
have lost their lives during these
conflicts ahead of these solemn silence
of Armistice Day the remembrance Rumble
seemed a fitting way for these former
Special Forces to pay their respects in
the end it wasn't about winning it was
about remembering